[Music]
the outsiders ravage our lands
their cruelty to my people is all i've
known
so you're going tomorrow yes i'm going
tomorrow to advance in i'd like you to
take me with you
are you trying to give me corn marshall
can i trust you something
i've been having dreams about a girl
falling in battle
felt like a vision
dreams make good stories but everything
important happens when we're awake
to the future of house of treaties
you have to be ready
there is no call we do not answer there
is no faith that we betray
they're not human they're
if i'm not brutal
you'll still be the only thing i ever
needed you to beat come on
listen
i know you
tonight the bloodline ends forever
kill them all
this is an extermination
they're picking my family off one by one
only together
[Music]
can we stand a chance let's fight like
demons
it's not safe for you here
i must not fear
fear is the mind killer
the fear is gone
homie will remain
[Music]
this is only the beginning
[Music]
you